[Music]
mike is in boise idaho hey mike how are
you
hey guys how are you doing today better
than i deserve what's up
well uh thank you for taking my call i'm
hoping you guys can help
maybe settle a discussion my wife and i
are having uh on the last item in our
snowball
um i we uh i bought a
uh 2014 ford raptor shelby
about six months ago so we and um
yeah to uh to fix up and actually flip
that was the intent
um we got a pretty good deal
well okay so my wife actually fell in
love with a wrap this is funny
with the raptor i love it
she uh i love this one she's got a
little bit of a so
she's got a little bit of anxiety while
driving and for whatever reason
when we get in this truck and drive on
the freeway and visit our relatives
she doesn't have anxiety driving i drive
one every day i love her she's safe
so she loves it so so where we're at
right now is we paid everything off with
that
and what do you want you know i what's
that what do you owe on it
oh thirty about thirty thousand like
what's your household income
175 okay and then what's your question
so my question is we're deciding on
whether or not to sell it right now
yeah i purchased it with the idea to
flip it it's worth about 45 to 50
depending on the buyer right now
because it's kind of that special
supercharged package the whole thing
my concern with selling is we haven't
got very far
in retirement i'm 43 and
we were thinking hey if we sell this
we're done we'll put a little cash in
our pocket
um but you know we enjoy driving it so
much it makes the traveling so nice
she's down on the fence where she'd like
what's your other car what's your other
car worth what
uh let's see she's got a 2014 escape and
it's like maybe 15 grand
and that's the only other you only have
two cars no no sorry so
so when i talk to the gal so i've got a
couple of especially vehicles and that's
one of the reasons that
i'm kind of leaning towards selling i've
got a couple early broncos
as well um that i've had for years
um a good time and so i fixed them up
restored them and they're in the garage
so
how much are they working mike how much
are they
yeah they're worth 100 grand yeah so the
one i have is an all original
uncut one it's probably worth in the
sixty thousand dollar neighborhood and
then the
one that's more of a toy it's probably
worth mid-forties i would say
okay you got a lot tied up in cars now
those
those two cars there i'm gonna pull them
to the side
because they're probably not going down
in value they're specialty vehicles
they're collectibles
uh but ninety percent of the time
ninety-eight percent of time you buy
something with wheels or motors it's
going down in value
and you just don't wanna have too much
tied up in toys you guys got a lot in
toys
we do and that's kind of where we're
both trying to have the discussions
for you to the broncos say that one more
time please how emotionally tied are you
to the broncos
um one of them i'm pretty emotionally
tied to just because of what it is i
mean the other one is so i mean i am i'm
emotionally tied to them they're so rare
i can never replace them
no that's true i love how honest you are
mike i like how you're trying
so it might be i mean i was just
thinking because i'm a car guy and i'm
into all
all these cars you're talking about i
love every one of them these are you got
some sweet stuff there
you got good taste i i'm probably
dropping a bronco and keeping the raptor
but that's just
me that's just me yeah
i don't care what you do i'm a little
bit afraid with all four of them you got
an awful lot tied up in rolling stock
with 170 000
income okay yeah you're gonna get that
you're gonna get the 30 paid off and
you're going to retire a millionaire i'm
not
worried about that i just want you you
got to stop buying cars i know that
yeah well especially ones you keep
that's right
because you know mike you're only a few
months away from finding another one
i'm with you dave pick a bronco
sacrifice it i
pay off the raptor put mama in that put
mama in that raptor what you think he's
going to drive the escape
no chance there's
sell the escape that's what i'm saying
that's true
yeah get rid of that thing and then drop
the only thing on this list that i
don't care about yeah get rid of that
thing
sorry escape this is a boy discussion
right here oh
i don't know man that's a hard one that
is tough just you don't want too much
tied up in rolling stock get rid of the
dead if you're going to keep it for sure
you don't want to keep the dead around
and i don't blame you for having this
discussion oh this is a good one
this is a good one